Дуже вам вдячний Пане президенте друзі
Хотів би розпочати зі слів подяки за
вкрай потужну резолюцію яку ми зробили у
Люксембурзі і сподіваюся що сьогоднішня
наша резолюція в Копенгагені буде навіть
більш
потужною Отож розпочну з так званої
втоми від України сьогодні вночі кілька
годин тому я втратив свого друга
командира 206 батальйону Віталія барано
його серце зупинилося в районі лиману на
лиманському напрямі наших бойових дій за
цих обставин втома від України означала
б втому від демократії втому від свободи
та нарешті втому від
НАТО а отже хотів би підтримати слова
прем'єр-міністра про те що допоки
Україна має сили боротися ніхто не має
права на втому Що слід робити саме зараз
по-перше не існує інших підходів НАТО
щодо наступальної або контрнаступальної
операції окрім як за умов домінування в
повітрі Тому нам потрібні винищувачі f16
або шведськи гріпен як потрібен
протиповітряний захист дальнобійні
ракети та боєприпаси слід перевести
економіку найбільшу економіку світу на
військові рейки у військовому режимі із
тим щоб перемогтирос у протистоянні
постачання
зброї позиція друга санкції адже слід
нарешті відрізати Росії можливості
фінансувати цю
війну і позиція третя А може це і
найперша позиція Ми всі маємо зрозуміти
що не буде Миру на нашому континенті без
членства України в НАТО не існує жодного
іншого ефективного механізму безпеки
окрім НАТО членство України в альянсі
означатиме стабільну ситуацію у сфері
безпеки на всьому
континенті Отже Хотів би запитати
заступника Генерального секретаря
по-перше якими є ваші очікування від
саміту НАТО у Вашингтоні в частині
запрошення для України адже ми маємо
вікно можливостей для цього Що має
зробити Україна з тим щоб пришвидшити
відповідне рішення тим більше беручи до
уваги що зараз ми перебуваємо тут у
Копенгагені і готові забезпечити
відповідні
реформи